russes et donc plus vite elle
disparaître vous êtes déjà plus de 10
millions avoir téléchargé tout senti que
vides et ce n'est qu'un début
tous antico vide c'est aussi le meilleur
moyen de générer vos attestation de
sortie ceci est un message du
gouvernement
écoutez il se passe toujours quelque
chose dans à l'abordage
[Musique]
chevallier c'est sûr discuté tous les
vendredis à la bombe ont fait vivre le
carnaval autrement 16h 18h sur
martinique la première
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
bonjour un bonne journée à toutes et à
tous frais de lordinot bonjour bonjour
bertrand qui a jugé bon toujours à
toutes et à toutes celles qui nous
écoutent merci d'être présent dans ce
studio vous êtes quatrième vice
président de l'assemblée de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
l'assemblée deux martinique et vous est
également cofondateur du mouvement
convergence progressis matinik acronyme
kpn un rassemblement créé en avril 2010
est on en parlera certainement au cours
de cet entretien
mais d'abord frais de lordinot puisque
c'est vous qui aviez mis le feu aux
poudres pour ainsi dire faisons un point
sur le fameux dossier séguinaud où en
est on et avec le recul est ce que cette
affaire devenue emblématique du bilan de
la première mandature de la ctm est ce
qu'il n'ya pas eu finalement beaucoup de
bruit pour rien puisque aux yeux de
certains la thèse finalement du
président du conseil exécutif alfred
marie-jeanne l'aurait semble-t-il
emporté y compris du côté de la
préfecture
mais il ya une plate je crois pendante
devant le tribunal administratif aussi
faisons le point
merci de m'avoir invité berlin car oui
j'essaie de 6 est important puisqu'il
s'agit de fournir l'eau potable à des
milliers de martiniquais une convention
transactionnel qui a été voté par
l'assemblée
il y a 6 mois si la convention avait été
appliqué le problème serait réglé
définitivement un problème qui dure
depuis 2009 il y a hélas une procédure
devant le tribunal administratif
un premier recours déposés là ça vaut
toujours 11 11 élus aux yeux de
l'assemblée et dénoncée y était guettée
oyola dont un imam un recours pour excès
de pouvoir parce que le président du
conseil exécutif a excédé ses pouvoirs
et un recours contre le représentant de
l'état en martinique qui lui a tenté une
tutelle sur une assemblée souveraine ce
qui est illégal donc rocco ils ont à la
fois le président du conseil exécutif
ainsi que leur effet jusqu'à mi-février
on va dire pour faire leurs réponses
mémoire réponse à un recours de nos
conseils
et puis y aura au mois de février la
décision de prendre ou pas cette fameuse
servitude est hélas la procédure va
continuer
c'est à dire que cette affaire va durer
encore alors que le feuilleton
il lui était si simple d'appliquer la
convention écrite mois des travaux
vont-ils démarré là où ont-ils déjà
démarré est ce que il faut attendre la
décision de justice où est ce que
finalement le président du conseil
exécutif n'a pas de délibération s'il
fait des travaux ces travaux sont
illégaux et je mets en garde les
entreprises martiniquaises qui seraient
tenter d'exécuter dans ces conditions
des travaux il ya beaucoup de pression
qui se font sur les entreprises il n'a
ni engagement juridique ni engagement
comptable le président du conseil
exécutif doit exécuter les décisions de
l'assemblée nous sommes dans un cas
avéré de dénis la démocratie et chacun a
pu le constater le président du conseil
exécutif lui-même disait en 2015 qu'il
devait exécuter les décisions de
l'assemblée
alors justement à l'occasion alors il ya
une partie de la majorité 1 qui avait
accédé aux manettes de la ctn en
décembre 2015 qui a fait à l'occasion de
rentrée politique
le bilan le bilan donc notamment la
semaine dernière à la rentrée du mime et
le président du conseil exécutif
lui-même ses collaborateurs ont indiqué
que finalement il n'y a pas à rougir de
ce bilan
ils n'ont pas démérité en citant
quelques chantiers emblématiques et puis
égratignant au passage une partie de
cette alliance qui donc a pris des
distances vous quel regard vous jeter
sur ces six années
alors évidemment il faut synthétiser
résume énormément mais voilà en résumé
une team is up poursuivi ce qu'on avait
commencé
ils n'ont pas réussi à terminer le lycée
schoelcher ils n'ont pas réussi à
terminer le pôle université sera
inaugurée la avant même les élections
oui mais c'est ce qui s'est fini c'est
ce qu'ils disent aujourd'hui a pas de
rentrer car il n'ya pas d'élèves dans le
lycée l'a alors que ça fait cinq ans il
que les gars vont commencer les fonds
européens
ils ne sont pas utilisés enfin bon on
peut pas dire qu'ils n'ont rien fait
mais le bilan est décevant
la réalité c'est que vous avez des
centaines d'entreprises qui ne sont pas
payés
les retenues de garanties ne sont pas
payés aux entreprises du btp le marin
pêcheur sang dans la rue
les écoliers ne sont pas contents parce
qu'on aurait pu leur donner à chacun une
tablette 15 millions d'euros numérique
pour progresser les martiniquais dans le
transport avait coûté demandé aux
habitants de chercheurs ce que ça vaut
le transport donc le bilan qu'il est
très largement négatif depuis décembre
le président du conseil exécutif nos dit
qu'il est candidat à sa propre
succession en fait depuis plus d'un an
on a campagne électorale de manière
incessante et la martinique est dans la
situation que vous savez alors justement
on parle de campagne électorale y aura
très probablement le renouvellement de
la ctm en juin prochain
où en êtes vous vous même par rapport à
aca pm et puis votre positionnement quoi
est ce que vous comptez participer à
cette campagne est ce que vous souhaitez
continuer le travail au sein de la ctm
ou est ce que vous ferez autre chose
après juin 2021 prédéfinis les les
membres surtout qu'à ceux qui
sympathisent qui gravitent autour de kpn
seront qui est quoi exactement ça parcel
service élections que nous avons créé un
cercle de réflexion où il voit là pour
faire émerger des idées
l'une des idées qui a émergé c'est la
baisse du prix de l'eau financée par
l'état qui devra nous payer nous
rembourser les coûts de traitement de
l'eau voilà une idée qui est sorti de
notre cercle de réflexion nous disons
pour l'eau tarif social de l'eau baisse
du prix de l'eau très unique de l'eau et
programme de rénovation des réseaux ça
c'est une idée qui est sorti de notre
chef de réflexion une autre idée qui est
sorti aussi du cercle de réflexion sur
son les investissements massifs pour le
réseau routier ce qu'on appelle la dette
grises c'est-à-dire les les sommes que
vous devez dépenser chaque année pour
entretenir votre code il ya même un
fonds spécifique dédié en septembre et 3
4 ans les sommes consacrées aux réseaux
routiers ont été divisés par cinq et
d'où les accidents que vous avez à
sainte-marie glissement de terrain a à
la fois à monter au dos et puis à
francin chaque donc pas certain nombre
d'idées qui je l'espère seront reprises
par les partis passer ce que j'allais
dire vous allez liberté à qui ses idées
vous avez déjà
réfléchissez chaque vous avez travaillé
positionnement ja nous voulons mettre en
place ce qu'on appelle un socle de
convergence des projets économiques
sociaux culturels environnementaux que
chacun peut reprendre pour que nous
n'ayons pas une campagne électorale où
il s'agit de querelles de personnes mais
un débat de fond ou le martiniquais
sortir de là bien attention alors on va
parler un peu stratégie politique
puisque parmi les onze il ya les
consignataires par exemple du recours en
justice contre la décision donc du pc et
du préfet dites-moi des voix de
l'opposition et de la majorité se sont
mêlés la vouvoie se sont mêlées à celles
de jean philippe ni lord claude lise par
exemple en trop non non le collègue
miller n'a pas participé au cou ni les
membres de pays à ce qu'il faut dire
c'est qu'il y avait fait plonger la
liste il y a effectivement à la tête
c'est peut-être raison mais le vérifier
il ay ay ay mon plaisir le premier vice
président mais je vais pas citer nicolas
est reçu à dakar du genre vous avez
raison effectivement j'ai récité mais
c'est pour voir verts qui vous allez
allez claude lise yan monplaisir
effectivement vous avez raison
marie-france tools fred lordinot donc
les onze signataires cora bernabé félix
catherine génie du 10 petit raphaël
martin diane montrose carling mousseau
daniel robin bon voilà effectivement je
me suis je corrige jean philippe miller
ne fait pas partie de cette liste
ce qu'il ya c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
rangs de l'opposition grossistes et je
dis bienvenue aux collègues qui rejoint
les rangs de l'opposition qui prennent
acte de l'échec de la mandature
aujourd'hui bondues du mime parce que le
président de l'assemblée dénonce
régulièrement il l'a fait encore
dimanche dernier les pratiques
autoritaires la dérive autoritaire les
pratiques antidémocratiques du président
du conseil exécutif il n'y a pas
l'organigramme de la collectivité n'est
pas connu par les élus on ne connaît pas
l'inventaire on n'a pas les informations
financières figurent vous gâtera jusqu'à
aujourd'hui 19 janvier la collectivité
n'a pas voté son budget primitif 2021
quand l'état a voté un plan de relance
de 100 milliards et l'union européenne a
voté 750 milliards dead pour les états
vous voyez que aujourd'hui c'est
l'immobilisme et
ray collègues toutes tendances
confondues aujourd'hui participent à
cette idée que nous avons développées à
kpn c'est qu'il faut très largement
rassembler au delà des clivages entend
rejoindre une liste en tant que telle
non n'ont pas rejoint de liste mais
chaque cheval individuellement chacun
sera libre s'il veut participer sur tel
ou tel exactement est libre de son
consentement il sa part dit pas je
voudrais pas terminer sans que nous
évoquions le carnaval puisque nous
sommes à quelques semaines en principe
des jours gras quelle est votre opinion
là-dessus quel est votre positionnement
est ce que vous estimez que c'est le
représentant de l'état
ici le préfet qui doit décider pour les
martiniquaises et les martiniquais à
propos de notre carnaval j'ai envie de
dire où est ce que il faut que ce soit
quelque chose en participation citoyenne
que les élus soient consultés les maires
peut-être vous mêmes conseillers
territoriaux enfin voilà très clairement
le représentant de l'état il passa la
ligne face à google et 2 mauguio et hip
hop on est culture ni pratique nous donc
il peut dire de modèles mais oui c'est
ça jeter un oeil mais voila voila il
part en pétant je le dis très clairement
donc les élus martiniquais doivent se
rassembler association des maires
c'était m communauté de communes pour
voir quelles associations sidéral
sensible naturellement une concertation
tout ça avec les actifs les associations
docteur organiser une large concertation
pour voir comment et l'idée que je prône
c'est un carnaval très fortement
numérisés c'est à dire comme les
guadeloupéens se contenter de le faire
dans vos studios avec sur internet et
participation des concours d'un deux
masques et pourquoi pas mais surtout je
voudrais saluer l'initiative des 80 deux
professionnels de santé les médecins
martiniquais qui audi fait attention et
faites vous vacciner
merci fred lordinot d'avoir répondu à
nos questions mais il ya bientôt une
journée voit aujourd'hui médaille à tous
[Musique]